in order to put the customer first knew
has to be the person they talk to at all
times we've noticed that with a lot of
other products there was one
organization selling you the policy
another organization that would uh that
you'd need to contact if you had a
problem there was a third one if you
needed to file a claim and there was
just no consistency and everyone was
motivated by different aspects of it so
really the fundamental Insight was was
first and foremost that that if you put
the customer first and if you made it
that you were legally and legally and
practically allowed to handle every
single part of the customer's Journey
with you it was much easier to create a
meaningful and memorable experience for
them
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside fam Fusion VC Birthright Excel
J impact leap Google for startups and
hippo and in media partnership with ctek
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today we're talking about travel
insurance from an unlikely upbringing
Faye is such an interesting company from
the Israeli ecosystem and this
conversation with Daniel Green is all
about the formation of Fae how they
figured what they need to be building
the responses they've been getting and
what they've been learning
Daniel Green is co-founder and CTO of
Faye the number one disruptor setting a
new standard in travel insurance
coverage and care this is the second
startup he has founded with fake
co-founder and CEO El ad Shaffer both
previously co-founded Wiki struck the
world's first crowd-sourced consultancy
platform there Daniel developed the
company's core Technologies including a
real-time collaboration platform
gamification incentification systems and
its Flagship data model for predicting
disruptions to countries and economies
as a developer with 20 years of
experience and a deep passion for travel
Daniel enjoys applying his
specialization in real-time applications
to phase core mission of forever
elevating the way consumers travel
Dan Green welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you so much for being here how are
you thank you for having me I'm awesome
I'm really excited to uh to pick your
brain on on these awesome things you're
working on in the travel insurance space
um you know travel is a such a big big
topic over the last few years
um ups and downs but obviously something
that we all enjoy taking part in and
it's a great privilege um and right
before we get we start talking about
what you're doing today I have to hear
the story about predicting flight delays
and what happened there because it
sounds first of all it sounds awesome
but it also sounds a little bit
connected to to what you're working on
sure so I've been lucky enough to be
traveling a lot in my lifetime I started
by working in in theater and I was
traveling between two cities uh and then
moved to Israel uh started a company
with my my current CEO so we've been
co-founders for like 12 years and we
were having to travel all the time to
meet clients
um and at some point it got to the point
where I was traveling overseas multiple
times sometimes in a week
um and you just started to pick up these
little intuitions about uh what was
making flights work and not work and you
started having long layovers you talked
to people at the airport I like chatting
to people on the plane and you just
start to learn that there's this whole
crazy ecosystem of travel there's this
universe of gamification that they use
for their frequent flyer programs
um and at some point it got to the point
where I was able to get on a plane once
in a while ask the crew what the
consequences would be of a delay and
they would say what delay and it would
turn out I was right
awesome and then one of those times they
actually rewarded you for picking up on
that right
yeah the pilot was impressed enough that
uh came out after we after we were in
the air to ask Howe how I guessed it
before anyone else did and I I explained
what what my intuition was and and what
I read in the radar report
um and I was going to miss a connection
on a flight to uh to New Jersey I really
wanted to meet I had a I had a new niece
that I really wanted to see and so what
they ended up doing was because I'd
become friends with the pilot he'd put a
call into the ground so when we landed
at Heathrow uh someone met me at the
door uh with a car drove me across the
tarmac we got to uh we got to the X-ray
machine for the second flight they said
if there's a bottle of water in this bag
you are not going to make it we we made
it to the flight they closed the door
behind me and after we took off someone
actually came up and asked who I was uh
assuming I was a celebrity I think that
held the flight for about 10 minutes so
I could make it
um and I wrote a few thank you letters
after that and I used to be known around
the airport that they actually had the
photographs of me and the niece hanging
out hanging up some running the airports
I'd walk into the airport they'd
recognize me as well it's a really fun
world to be part of
I I love it I love it okay tell me a
little bit about travel insurance and
everything in between what what is sort
of the the underlying understanding that
that your new co-founder had when
starting this company
sure so we didn't start by doing travel
insurance we we started uh with the
Insight that when things go wrong when
you're traveling what matters the most
is
um having information available to you
faster than everyone else so if there's
five seats left on the next plane the
first five people to know that are the
most likely to get out of town and
sometimes you could land at an airport
where if you missed the train between
terminals you're not going to make it
but if you knew that there's a service
passage that anyone can walk down you've
still got a shot at making that flight
and and you just need that information
exactly when you need it so we started
off as a smart travel assistant we
launched in uh the very end of 2019
really January 2020 so you know where
the punch line of this is going
um and and just as we were really taking
off people were signing up for the the
travel assistant uh on a daily basis uh
suddenly covert hit and we we still had
people continue to use us and we were
collecting Amazing Stories from people
who were traveling with a smart
assistant that we nicknamed any at the
time because uh made you more Zen and we
really understood that the missing piece
of what we were doing was it's all well
and good to have the inside information
it's all well and good to know in
advance that there's a prediction that
something will go wrong with your flight
but what's next and really for us the
missing piece uh was insurance so that's
that was the birth of of Faye as you
know today and we really understood that
uh so many people saw insurance as a
reimbursement service something that
they dealt with only when they got home
and we really wanted to change that we
really wanted to be something you used
uh even if something didn't go wrong on
your trip and that was why we became
about creating a consumer-centric smart
offering that was top coverage 24 7
assistance no excessive paperwork
real-time alerts like everything you
need to make your trip a success not
just a reimbursing service when things
go wrong
what what did you figure out about
creating sort of this trust with with
the consumers you're mentioning that you
have to create a there's a consumer
Behavior shift here from thinking about
insurance companies as sort of this
reimbursory type mechanism to actually
companion on travel what what what steps
did you have to do that did you that you
found were most helpful in creating that
creating that distinction
so I think for us the the single biggest
thing we did from uh from a company
point of view is that we actually built
um the ability to handle claims which
from a legal and Regulatory point of
view uh is an incredibly complicated
undertaking but we really started with
this philosophy that in order to put the
customer first knew has to be the person
they talk to at all times we've noticed
that with a lot of other products there
was one organization selling you the
policy another organization that would
uh that you'd need to contact if you had
a problem there was a third one if you
needed to file a claim and there was
just no consistency and everyone was
motivated by different aspects of it so
really the fundamental Insight was was
first and foremost that that if you put
the customer first and if you made it
that you were legally and legally and
practically allowed to handle every
single part of the customer's Journey
with you it was much easier to create a
meaningful and memorable experience for
them
um and and you were only motivated by
making the customer uh as comfortable as
you can and looking after them as best
you can and you're not worried about you
know someone else down the chain you're
not United Airlines selling a policy on
behalf of another company or a
Clearinghouse for claims working on
behalf of an insurance carrier and and
obviously you're the you're the chief
technology officer here so tell me a
little bit about the technology that
goes into perhaps automating a lot of
this personal personalized experience
because then as you scale you need to be
able to to offer that to a lot of people
in real time and and create that trust
sure so there's there's two parts to it
there's there's actually when you go to
buy a product and then when you need to
interact with us afterwards so one of
the things that people got very used to
is the idea that you would enter uh
dozens of pieces of information when
buying a policy and then you'd be shown
three or four different plans to choose
from or different carriers that maybe
there'd be a bronze silver gold version
of the plan and so we actually made the
decision to make you just one offer we
asked you five or six questions about
your trip we look into all the
information that we might be able to
gather about other people that have had
similar similar itineraries we
understand that someone traveling to
London is not necessarily the same as
someone traveling to Madrid which is not
the same as someone traveling to Ibiza
even though sometimes the insurance is
rated the same so we don't ask you to
choose from plans we present what we
believe is the best coverage for your
needs we don't let you buy coverage you
can't use so for example cancel for any
reason can't be used within 48 hours a
week your trip so if you're traveling in
36 hours we won't even offer it to you
the only things you can toggle is are
you traveling with your pet and are you
hiring a car and so that means that you
can go from opening our website to being
covered by us in less than a minute so
long as you know your trip dates uh
which and we just took all the the
thinking and questioning out of it if
you don't like what we're offering it's
okay you can go with other companies but
we've offered you what we think is the
best and most appropriate package and
then the second part I'm sorry no no go
ahead go ahead
and then the second part is what happens
after that so we offer you instantly a
mobile app to download we ask you to
enter your flight information and other
bits of your booking so that we can
start to send you alerts in advance we
know there's an earthquake in that area
we know in advance your flight's going
to be delayed we'll even tell you that
you're entitled to a compensation for
let's say a delayed flight or a
misconnection before you need to reach
out to us when you have a claim and
we're able to process some of that
information instantly using computer
vision and the like all the way through
to actually pushing a credit card
through to your phone so if you need to
pay for something in trip
um so long so long as it's approved and
it falls in the right categories we can
actually issue you an Apple pay or a
Google pay card on the swipe for you to
use before you even get home
interesting and so obviously still
people go to the website they have to
choose between getting your services
versus a lot of the incumbents that that
while maybe there's you know they're
more on the reimbursory type of mindset
they're still you know there there's
larger players that have that have long
sustaining Brands is it is it was it
trivial to get people to buy into this
and say yeah we trust that Faye will be
here when we need them besides the great
brand and the great messaging how do you
get them to actually believe that you
are going to be there for them up to you
know pre-pre-purchasing how do you get
them to actually go ahead and choose you
over over others
so firstly I think covert was not just a
massive accelerator for people wanting
travel insurance in the first place like
it was the event where a lot of people
had really bad experiences with their
existing travel insurance maybe they
thought that their credit card would
cover something and they didn't realize
it wasn't maybe they thought they were
covered for the entirety of their trip
that they were only covered up to a few
hundred or a few thousand dollars so I
do think one of the advantages we have
at the moment is we're not one of the
incumbent there are a lot of people that
had bad experiences the major brands
during covert and they're looking for a
new player that's pricing to make a
difference and I think that's a really
significant part of what leads people to
trust us and I think the other part is
we've worked really hard to create a
friendly welcoming brand I think most
travel insurance products look very
corporate uh very generic they have
stock images they all follow a very
similar format and there's a lot of
people that even coming to the home page
of the website already feel like okay
this is different to the incumbents
let's give these guys a try
interesting tell me a little bit about
your own your own personal Journey you
mentioned that you've been traveling a
lot and you obviously seem really
excited about what you're doing here but
but what what role does this play sort
of in your own personal journey in your
own life
so I grew up in Sydney Australia and
there's everyone who grew up on on an
island I guess a little bit like uh
people who live in places like Israel
there's a huge desire to get out and and
travel so
um even growing up travel was was kind
of part of the ethos of being Australian
uh I was lucky enough to work in the
entertainment industry I did real-time
programming for uh for film theater and
television which led to all sorts of
interesting adventures and that that in
itself
um allowed for a little bit of travel
I've been lucky enough to interact with
computers back in the days where they
were black and green screens
um you really had to tell it uh step by
step in fact I think the first thing I
used to save things on was audio
cassettes produce them as disk drives uh
back in the 80s and uh and so part of
that became a passion for real-time
programming when you worked in theater
if something goes wrong you have
literally minutes to fix it before
people in the audience will start to
complain and sometimes there's even an
SLA that once once you've ruined about
six seven minutes of a show people can
start to ask for refunds and there's an
amazing culture that comes from all of
that wow um and then about 12 years ago
uh moved to Israel started a company
with my uh then and still current uh CEO
um and we were we were building
crowdsourcing systems for for
governments and uh governments large
corporations a lot of them that wanted
to meet in person even though we were a
remote company before remote was a thing
uh they really liked to meet in person
it's either you were real and so we
found ourselves on the front end
building this amazing expert Network
crowdsourcing platform and then on the
back end running a travel agency as we
were getting everyone in and out and
there was this real feeling you'd get a
phone call you might be sitting in
London having a meeting and someone
would call you in DC and say hey I've
got a great idea can we meet and so sure
let's meet next week and let's say ah
let's meet tomorrow and you just you'd
figure it out and then inevitably and
you'd miss a connection somewhere in New
York at two in the morning and you you
had to figure that part out as well so
I've always I've always been fascinated
by the systems that underpin the way the
world works so travel travel was a big
fun part of that
um especially if you get into the the
nice bridge between the psychology of
travel which is everything from how
people feel like when they travel to the
frequent flyer programs and the
Incredible World of gamification that
underlines you know how we can get you
to stay super loyal to one Airline for
the vague possibility that you'll get to
board three minutes earlier than
everyone else
um and and as you kind of go up the
ladders of traveling you also get to
experience that you start getting
breeded on planes you start getting
greeted at airports
um and you get the occasional upgrade
and all of that really gets you to think
about the algorithms and systems and
data that goes into Airlines making
those decisions as well and so I've I've
always worked in in sort of data heavy
real-time
situations and travel insurance is kind
of the ultimate culmination of that we
we get scenarios now where people
sometimes call into the support center
uh at the gate as their flight is
boarding with a problem and they're
asking us not just can we fix it but can
we fix it in the six minutes before
wow and so tell me a little bit about
you know your role as the chief
technology officer and sort of how
technology how you see technology
playing role here because obviously
you're so passionate excited about what
you're doing and you're talking a lot
about the psychology of it and the the
trust and the brand how do you see the
technology being a part of it and what
is sort of your role as a technology
leader in making that happen
sure so I'll break it into two sections
so the most obvious side is when it
comes to Insurance there is the entire
world of Actuarial science and math
that's known as underwriting and travel
insurance has traditionally been uh a
bit of a less sophisticated product uh a
lot of them just don't differentiate
between what airline you're flying where
you're going to what class you're flying
um and so so part of that is
understanding can we start to collect
and map and model the data today that
will allow us to eventually approach a
regulator in places like the US and have
much more sophisticated underwriting and
pricing and really just optimize at the
end of the day the whole concept of
insurance is we all put ten dollars into
a pipe with the agreement that if
everything goes perfectly well we we our
ten dollars went paid for someone else's
Misfortune and I think a lot of people
forget that and then the second part is
how can you scale customer experience
right and how can you it's one thing to
take a phone call from someone at the
gate who wants you to troubleshoot but
when it is uh the sort of claim again as
some people are calling it right now
with just how many things that are going
wrong you don't want to be manually
processing everyone's baggage forms can
people take photographs can you take a
GPS location what are all the things you
can kind of automatically collect in
advance so that you can still comply
with all the regulation that comes with
insurance that you can still get the
paperwork uh prepared on the back end
without the customer having to suffer
through those processes I mean the
number of insurance products that
require you to write out your name email
address and policy number on six
different pieces of paperwork when the
company that sold you the policy has
known that from the beginning so it's
been a really interesting challenge to
build the team
um here in Tel Aviv and a few other
places of people that are super
passionate about travel and are really
thinking about how we can digitize
common sense so that so that computers
can make quick smart and legally
compliant decisions wherever possible
and the rest of the time it can just
prepare something for a human to just
sort of be in the loot uh tick off that
it works and then only deal with the
more complicated personal stuff
awesome and so what do you think is
going to really make Faye win at the end
you know what how what is sort of this
underlying underlying strategy that
you're saying you know this is why I
think Faye is going to be a market
leader in in the travel companionship
Insurance space
so I think we're already seeing some of
that now I mean we've only been in the
market for four months and we have
people returning for their second and
third trip with us which is incredible
um and I know it's not a technology
answer but I really believe that that
concept of caring about the customer as
a philosophy has so many amazing side
effects or Consequences for the company
it means that people tell their friends
it means that people come back uh in in
America most people really think about
trip and travel insurance as something
they buy on a case-by-case basis they
have no loyalty they don't remember who
they worked with uh the previous time
maybe they just kicked a box when they
were buying their flight so I think
having a brand having people know your
name and care about you is is really
what causes people not to think I need
travel insurance but to think I'm
traveling I better check that I've got a
policy or a plan set up with Faye
um and and I even see it now that people
sometimes write in with a claim and the
response that comes from the claim team
doesn't start with Dear Sir it starts
with oh no that's terrible can you tell
me more about what happened which is
right completely new experience for the
customer and lead them to say we've had
people who we've denied claims and
they've still said wow just thanks to
Kerry and I understand it didn't fit in
with the policy and we've had people
where we've approved claims and they've
said just so you know the airlines just
paid me back so I'd like to cancel the
claim because you guys were so nice and
so so powerful in the way you treated me
as a human that I don't want to double
dip and I can't imagine that happens
with a lot of other companies right I
think that we saw a lot of it you know
especially from personal experiences you
can always say like what's customer
service I remember that was a big change
in sort of A disruption of how you treat
you know a lot of these a lot of these
mishaps and I remember though you know
sort of working with Emojis and the oh
no type of type of mindset I think it's
just I mean that's where we're heading
and that's what people look for people
want to be heard ultimately Beyond just
the claim and it's sounds like you're
working on some really really
fascinating fascinating things and and I
look forward to using Faye myself and
thank you very much for joining me for
these 20 minutes sharing your own
stories sharing the story of Fame what
you've learned and I'm looking forward
to cheering from the side thank you
absolutely my pleasure